So if everyone could welcome Zach at bars,
the creator of electronics,
Space Chem in minor or Gis,
100 Schengen io and various other games.
[inaudible]
thank you. Okay, so the
first thing's first,
I want to share a secret with you guys.
Just that I hate talks and they're
really boring and they're just God.
I mean I've been to GDC so many years
that the game dollars conference and just
sitting there and having somebody just
kind of talk at you with like they're
preplanned deck of slides
and it's not very fun.
So what I wanted to try doing this
time had it, mix it up a little bit,
do some Q and a.
Uh,
so you guys apparently asked a bunch of
questions and voted on the best ones and
we don't actually know if the people
who asked the questions are here today.
Raise your hand if you ask
a question on the website.
Did any of you actually ask a question?
Okay.
Did you ask all the questions?
So I guess you're going to have
to do the proxy. Okay. That,
that kind of throws a wrench in that.
Okay.
So I was going to have
people ask questions and
then answer them and ask them
followup questions. But apparently
I can't do that. So, um, I dunno.
I think it'd be cool to make
this. So it's not like I, I have,
instead of repairing a giant slide deck,
I prepared a couple of smaller ones.
I'm going to start with this one.
But then from there I have a bunch
of things that are sort of answers to
questions that might be asked by the
person who has a list of questions that
they're going to ask. So we'll
see how this goes. Okay. So, um,
how many people in the audience are
familiar with the Games that we've made?
So that's sort of like,
okay,
so are you flirt with all of them
or some of them are. Okay. So,
so when I was going to start with
is a, um, it's just sort of like a,
a history of how we got here and the
games that we've made so that we all have
like a shared context so we can
talk about games. So, um, so what,
so I started making,
making games when I went to college
and it just started off as a,
as a fun thing and you get some,
some lovely games like this,
which was the first game I guess I ever
made, which is for a game jam for, uh,
for the,
the Game Development Club where you're
supposed to make a game that your mother
wouldn't play. And I won because I was
the only person who bothered to try it.
So you can actually,
this is the probably the earliest
game that I've made that you can still
download. Like if you go to like our
secret old website on the Internet and a,
but it's really bad and it's terrible.
Uh,
another weird game that I made in
college is again, common fit of Frag,
which was terrible and I really had no
idea how to do any of the things that are
involved in making this happen from a
technical standpoint. But, uh, it, it,
as you may know, went on to start
some big stuff years later, uh,
through some other stuff
we'll got through. It was
a terrible game though. Um,
so there's, there's a game called
manufacturer that I made also terrible,
this sort of a trend here, um, in
which you, you would build factories.
And this was directly inspired by the
show, how it's made, where, you know,
it was back when I was less jaded about
making games and then I, you know,
I saw how it's made on TV and it was like,
wow, this is incredible. Like this is,
this is, you know, like
we're seeing how are made.
It would be so cool not to
like to make those things,
but to make a factory that makes things
like that. And, and that this game,
it doesn't really look like it,
but was sort of trying to get at that the,
the downside,
the biggest downside is probably that
you had to program in the Lula completely
unnecessarily. And that's like a god
awful experience. So that's that.
That was something, um, here's
a game called Rick engineer,
which was the like super credi kind of
exploration into a game about electrical
engineering, mechanics and
reverse engineering. Um,
the idea that it was going to get a point.
So there are these,
these test points where you could,
I mean, you can't even look at you,
you're there. Like they're automatically
tagged. This is a terrible interface. Um,
you can sort of interact with the circuits
at various tests points and you can
kind of reverse engineer the circuit and
tried to unlock the lock. And this was,
I mean,
if you're familiar with our earlier games,
this is kind of the beginning of,
you know,
an idea that reoccurs a lot of games
about electrical engineering. Um,
this was probably like the first kind
of puzzle game that I tried to make.
It was really terrible, but
it's about, uh, like sequential
transformation of data.
The idea of being that like there's
certain can you can't say that. Okay.
So there's that whole on the left
side where like data pulses come in,
which you're one of them different
colors and that you can apply like
transformations, like filtering
them by color and redirecting them.
And it's a horrible game. But again, kind
of gets us some, some early ideas. Um,
there's again fun silicon foundry
which is about, uh, you, you said you,
you build chips,
you build ships by assembling a little
parts that I don't think I really have
any pictures of it but it was sort of
like a little tetris pieces that would fit
together and they had different like input
and output requirements and you would
use it to satisfy like very abstracted
ideas of these different products you
could build.
And over the course of the,
and there are probably like 30 different
products that you built that are like
very simple simplifications of,
of electrical circuits that your
products and stuff like that.
And at this point it
should be kind of obvious,
like sort of what my background is is
that when I went to college it was for
computer science, computer engineering
and like all of these things that,
these ideas that I,
I'd sort of,
I known that they existed
before as somebody who used
computers and was fond of
computers.
But starting to see like sort of how
these things work behind the scenes.
It all starts coming out.
Not really in my classwork because there
was nothing special going on there.
But in a,
in these games that I'm building and uh,
there's some sort of other diversions
into other areas that are more gamey.
This is a game we made called Tex Mex
where you, uh, you ran around on a uh,
pat that's like a giant sheet
of carpet with like, uh,
like screen door material underneath
of it and it's like a really cruddy,
a pressure sensitive pads.
So we knew where you were standing and
then we took a hatch we mode and this is
right when the,
we came out and people were starting
to like kind of analyze the Bluetooth
protocol and figuring
out how to hack that.
I don't know if anybody was messing
around with that stuff when it happened,
but it was like, it was, it was
cool. It was really cool and I,
and for the first time in my life had
like the technological skills to actually
kind of do some of that stuff.
And so we took a we moat and took all
the guts out and jammed it into like a
piece of metal. So it was kind of like
a, like a lightsaber kind of thing.
And then made a game that
was like inspired by Gundam
kind of and like visually
kind of looked like it and you would
like run around and attack and,
and do stuff. And it's Sorta it, it's
like the connect before the connectors,
the thing. And it was
probably about as popular. So,
um, uh, yeah, so the,
the last game that I made in college was
as I was coming out to Seattle to work
at Microsoft was a game
called Rick engineer too.
And I would say this is probably the
first like modern electronics game. Uh,
this was the first one that actually
people really played to any degree on the
Internet. Uh, it got on Hakodate
so I submitted it to hacker Dan.
This was back in like really very,
very few people were following what we
were up to or what I was up to. And, um,
we got the link, I sent it to hack a damn
like you guys, like electrical stuff.
Here's the game that's about electrical
reverse engineering and they posted it
and this was back in 2008.
And,
and that was like the first time that
anything I'd ever made got in front of a
bunch of people and it was awesome and
a bunch of people came and played it and
that, that brought a lot of people to
my website and kept them coming back.
And that was back in like the blog era.
So that was like the way to do it I guess.
And uh,
and so this is a refined can war game,
your version of,
of the wreck engineer nasty game.
You saw it before and uh,
and it has like really terrible like
full motion video storytelling class.
I should have brought more of that
because it's there. It's like me,
me just straight out of college,
like dressed up with like whatever I could
find that looks like military surplus
clothing, like running around making
my, my now wife fill me as, I'm like,
we did like a sequence where I'm like
running through a field and like have to
like go disarm the bomb and like that's
all in there and it's adorable and
terrible. And Yeah. Uh, so,
so that sort of was the end of,
of the colleges have games and
got into the Microsoft here.
It's where I didn't actually
make games at Microsoft,
but I made games at night while I worked
at Microsoft and worked on office.
I worked on Vizio for
for three years and uh,
it was like the opposite of making games
when I, I worked briefly, I didn't, I,
when I was in college,
I did an internship at a studio
called breakaway games and they made,
it was like 50% expansion packs to like
eat like ea games and stuff and 50%,
uh, like real, like, um, like
serious games, I guess like game.
They made a game that was
like a simulation of like a
military hospital and like
one of their infamous bugs
is that patients would die
and then just get up and
start walking around anyway and stuff.
So they were like 50% serious,
50% expansions and I worked there.
I,
I briefly intern there during the summer
when you're and worked on a game that
was, it was like an
adventure game for kids like,
but it was made for the Middle Eastern
market and it was done by like a bunch of
like American businessmen who wanted
to promote American values of Bron.
So it's like a really weird introduction
to the games industry. And uh,
and so after like a summary of
that, I'm just like, you know what,
I don't really like games that much.
Like I had been designing games while I
was in college and then I go get a real
game design job and I'm just
like writing c plus plus,
which I'm not good at and still I'm
not good at. And it's just like, wow,
this is this.
I could just program anything.
And it would probably be about as fun. And
on that logic, I went to work on Vizio.
Uh, so, which was I guess not
true. So when I was there,
I worked on a lot of games.
Like probably right away I probably
started working on stuff for fun at night.
And that's how I swear making Flash Games.
So downloadable games were a thing,
I guess they still are. But, uh,
this was right when, when flash
games were really, really taking off,
as exemplified by the fact
that when I was in college,
I used to spend a lot of time
playing flash games in class.
And so as that was taken, I was like,
Oh, I'm gonna make some flash games.
So you get the bureau
of Steam Engineering,
which is a game about a seem engineering
in a context that's not really real
estate engineering, but in a,
in a context that didn't exist,
which is like a steam powered civil war,
which does the theme that comes up again.
Uh,
you get a game called the critics
of what chemical engineering, uh,
which is a game about alchemy where
you program a little arms to move atoms
around. This is both like the,
the it followup I guess, to,
to manufactory.
Like what if,
what if you could build a factory without
having to write Lula? That's this game.
Um, and then this later be obviously
become spacecom. Um, you can door,
which is something, uh, so, you know, so,
so this is a game about
building integrated circuits,
kind of, and it's again,
like stuff I learned in college
but didn't learn in college.
So this is not how real
integrated circuits work,
but it's kind of evocative of it. So that
was something, oh, you asked to see my,
my love of like, uh, like,
like Soviet nostalgia stuff,
kind of leaking through hearing. Um, uh,
I make a game called and fit a minor,
so my wife goes away,
back home to the east coast for the
weekend, and when she comes back,
I've made the beginnings of Infinera
minor. And, uh, and that's a story that's,
that's been a big thing in my life.
Uh,
so when I really have to get into the
infinite later story I guess, but, um,
so I made, I made this game, uh,
for me it was a sequel to Infinera frag
and kind of a way to explore like, oh,
what if we took those really terrible,
you know,
that block engine that could only render
like 30 blocks without like becoming a
performance and made it so we could render
an entire world out of blocks and a,
and that was Infinera minor and
accidentally started some other games,
genres and stuff.
We'll get into that later.
I'm sure somebody will have a
question about that. Um, uh,
then I made a game called space cab.
So this was our first commercial game
and I guess the first game where we're me
became an actual, we, um,
there were like six or eight people who
sit through some means worked on this
game. And this was right when, after,
I guess I'd say this is like my posts
braid game because braid came out and
castle crashers and that's like,
Holy Shit. Like you can be a nobody,
you can be not backed by a publisher
and make a ton of money and actually saw
your game.
And,
and that was inspirational because before
that I thought I'd have to give away
my games. Right. And we
look in a fit of minor,
like how could you ever
sell Infinera minor?
Like how could you sell a game like
that would never make money, right.
So this is really where
I was at at this time.
And obviously after seeing like space
Kim is also a post Minecraft game and the
seeing that like,
wow you can,
you can make a game and somebody
can make money off of it. And,
and so so so we made, we made space
cam and we thought, you know, God,
I mean I spent like five grand
of my own money, like as a,
as an advanced to our artists in the
Philippines and everybody else was just
working on profit sharing.
Cause I was like, okay,
this game we could probably make
like 10 grand. Right. And I was like,
but like if we happen to
make like a hundred grand,
like I'll quit my job and make games.
And so that just kind of instantly,
and that happened, like we made
the, I'm just like, okay, well no,
I'm not quitting my job.
Like that's not,
that's not enough money to sustain
like a bunch of people working.
We make it to three grand then or three.
I knew that 300 grand, like then, then,
then I'll quit my job and we
did. And it was like, Oh God,
I guess we have to do this now.
So I was actually, I was the,
so the core original electronics
is me and my friend Keith.
And so Keith went to Rpi with me.
He actually was there,
like when I was designing and fit of Frag,
it was his idea that in
order to build a block,
I'll have another block that you pointed
shoot at it. So I'm apparently act too.
So yeah, it's like, that's, that's like
I've been working with him for another,
with working with him on
stuff for a while. And, uh,
and so we were the first two
people to do Zach tronics.
We had like a tiny little office and he
actually quit Microsoft like a week or
two before me. That's how more dedicated
he was than me I guess. And uh,
and this is what started the, into years.
So our first game was ironclad tactics,
uh, which is kind of alive
because ironclad tactics
actually came out two years
after we started doing
sex tronics fulltime.
And during a period during
which we actually made a
bunch of educational games,
which I'll show you in a second, uh, we,
we thought this was going to
be like the hottest shit ever.
And if space Kim did this well,
like clearly ironclad tactics was
going to do this well because all the
complaints we heard about space camera
that like it didn't look good and it was
too hard. This game was
easier, it looks better.
And instead of selling this well and
instead of selling this will IX face him,
it's still like this fall. So, so
that was a bit of like a, a thing.
We can get into that later too. If you
need to. But during that time, we also,
the thing,
the reason I'm still like,
I'm here today and talking about making
games and kept doing it after us because
while we were doing in cloud tactics and
perhaps wondering some of our future on
that, we, um,
we made some educational games for a
company called amplify who was owned by
News Corp inexplicably.
It's felt like a zillion dollars building,
a tablet based curriculum that like
literally caught on fire. And uh,
and so they will only once, and it
might've been a power supply or something,
I don't know. So, um, so, so we
made a game about starch metabolism,
which is pretty cool for game and
let's starch metabolism. Um, they're,
they're all tablet games,
so it's, it's like pinball.
Acceptive pinball wasn't pinball
and you had a bunch of pinballs.
And so you flick the little particles
around and like, you know, like you,
you can push the button
to pump the, uh, like the,
the lungs and it brings in a new set of
air and then you can just take all the
oxygen out.
And I'm like,
swipe it into the one stream and said it
was pretty cool but it's terrible. Um,
the probably the best educational
game we, it was have a tactics, a,
a cooperative like eating
other creatures simulator.
It's Kinda weird.
It's matched three and like the animals
like have to line up to be eaten by the
next one up in the food pyramid.
But it's really cool because it represents
a haven't done how have habitats
where I can't send the word habitat
without saying have a tactics now,
which is it makes it hard to
be taken seriously. Um, so uh,
this is a game called factor,
which is when like Twitter and stuff
we're taking off and like the weird,
like we're going to take
out vowels in our name.
So that was all my idea of the
factor and maybe not, I don't even,
I love it regardless.
And it's a game where you,
you are the ship and you
move your finger around,
it follows the ship and you pick up
these numbers to take on the identity of
these prime numbers,
which allow you to then slice up
numbers that are divisible by it.
It's pretty cool for a math
game. Um, uh, so after,
after the fallout of ironclad tactics
and realizing like, oh dear God, this,
but this game was not going to make as
much money as we were hoping was going to,
we, we had to radically downsize and we
had to sort of think about like what the
hell are we doing? Right? Like we can't,
we thought that going into the Indy,
the Indy times that you could just make
any game and as long as it was fun,
people would find your game and
play it and you make lots of money.
It'd be great cause that's
what happened was face cam.
It turns out we accidentally did
something right. Let's face Kim,
I guess I really don't even like people
claim to know what goes on in the games
industry. I think they're all liars or
they just are confused or they did too.
Well, you know, we were sort of blessed
by doing well enough to still be around,
but not well enough that we can't just
like accidentally coast on our laurels
that we have to, we're always just
kind of getting by and uh, and so that,
that kind of thinking is what led to
Infinera factory. Um, God, there was,
so there was a long spirit period of
time in which I made and Finna minor and
then kind of felt bad about it and felt
like I couldn't really make another game
like that. Or It'd be weird to make a
block game and Infinera factors like,
you know what? No, like we
can make any games we want
about blocks. Like who cares?
Uh, it'd be cool to make a game
that's kind of like space can,
but in three d with blocks and you built
stuff like factories and like, I mean,
obviously you can see the repeating
themes and all of these games and that's
what in Finna factory and it did well.
Right? And so we went from thinking,
um,
like we'll never make a game that will
ever do as well as space camp ever again.
I, I legitimately believe that like that's
based on was just an element of timing
and that we'd never make a game like
that again and it would just never do as
well in Finna factor did better than
space cow soso apparently that's not true.
So I'm so that was sort of
a cool optimistic thing.
Also made a game called ts 100 which
almost didn't make um, I caught,
I wanted to stop making this game
so many times because it's terrible.
I was like no one is going to play this.
I I took it with me on my laptop.
Did you see one year and I had the
little printed out manual and I wanted to
like get some people to play test it and
I couldn't even bring myself to put it
in front of anybody to let them
play test it cause I'm just like no,
like this game is awful.
And we brought down the manual to show
somebody and they're just like, oh my God,
this is amazing. I'm
just like, really? So so,
so we kept working on it and we shipped
it and it was really just like a,
this was like a little side
project that was a, um,
I had started working on this other game
cause I was born and wanted to make a
different game while working on this too.
And it was going to be this big adventure
game with a bunch of different puzzles
in it. And that was not
clearly not going to happen.
You can't make two games at
once. So it's very hard. Um,
and ctis was just like a tiny little
portion of that game spun out into its own
little thing and,
and we shipped it and it actually did
really well and it did better than
ironclad tactics, like, right.
Like that's crazy. Like,
so clearly we don't understand how
games work at all, but we're successful.
The sort of irony here, I guess. Is that,
what's the next slide? Okay. Yeah. So, um,
the irony here is that these games did
well and I'd thought that nothing could
ever do as well as space.
Kim and I learned that these games did
well while I was working at valve after
having shutdowns electronics
because I was tired of failing.
And so that was sort of a weird thing.
And so VR was happening.
I felt kind of bad cause like none of
our games really did well and Vr was
happening and there was no
way we could make a VR game.
And it seemed like it was
important to work on it. And, uh,
and so I found myself at valve
and I worked on VR stuff there.
There's a question for
that. We'll get there. Um,
and then seemingly out of the
blue, uh, we, we sold Zach tronics.
So electronics is not owned
by me anymore. Thank God. Um,
that was the worst part of running
an indie studio. It turns out,
is owning it and having to do the
business stuff. I'm not a business person.
I'm not that clever or whatever it takes
to do business. And, uh, maybe not clever.
I don't know. Um, uh, so, so
needless to say, we actually,
we sold electronics and we now worked
for like a publisher distributor who's
also electronics. And it's great because
it allowed us to make Shinjin io,
which is awesome. Right? I mean this is,
this is perhaps like the
mosaic tronics he game yet.
And we made it while technically not
being indie, which is really exciting. Um,
because I didn't have to do the business
stuff and I didn't have to do our taxes.
So these are serious problems
that I had to deal with. Uh,
and uh,
yeah and so I suspect more of you are
familiar with [inaudible] out cause that's
like the new flashy one and a and stuff.
And that is the end of that.
So that sort of catches up
to where we are now that um,
we released this game like Decemberish
it came out of early access and,
and that's, that's,
that's the history so far.
Does anybody have any
questions about this part?
Just about anything you saw or any other
things I didn't mention or let me thing.
Okay. So we're going to take a couple of
questions from the door and open it up.
Okay.
The first question was,
what has been the most surprising or
unexpected thing that you've seen him play
or do with one of your games? Oh,
okay. Oh, what you want to come back?
So I actually have a whole another
presentation that shows off stuff,
but it might be better to like, okay.
Not just blast through more slides.
I was trying not to make us a slideshow,
but apparently we're,
we run in that that route.
Yeah.
How long do you spend designing the
court in logic of the game compared to
coming up with puzzles
for, oh, that's fine.
I definitely haven't heard
that question before now and,
but when you send it to me,
that was, that didn't work.
That was a joke that when
you're going, so, um,
what is this? This is not okay.
We're going to open this in here. Um,
so, so I Shinjin io is, is he an
Unix? Usually when I do all my design,
it's in a notebook. And which means
that like in terms of creating art,
if I don't really scan my notebooks so
it's hard to show off what's in them.
Aside from scanning then, which
I don't do a, we sent you an io,
it was designed not in the notebook.
And so this gives us an
interesting glimpse into
easily scannable documents that
show off the development of an out.
And have you guys already seen this,
this set of documents from ordering the
special edition? Anybody get the special,
the physical addition of
Schengen? Yeah. Okay, cool.
So most of you haven't seen this,
so um,
okay.
Okay. So like all good things. A
lot of my games start with a list.
So the idea obviously I guess like
when when we start working on a game,
when I start thinking of a game,
it's usually some kind of a lot of people
talking about game design in terms of
like emotional stuff.
You want to design something that
emotionally resonates with your players.
Like for me it's sort of like a,
as a program or like a mechanical
emotional resonance. Like, oh,
it would be cool if there was
a system that worked this.
Or like if you had a system where
like if we could take the idea of
microcontrollers and like how circuits
work and how like like modern embedded
systems work and turn that into a game.
Like there's,
for me there's a feeling there.
I don't know if other people have
feelings about like embedded programming
resonating on an emotional level.
But like there's a thing there.
There's a system and I think a lot of,
if you look at a lot of our games,
clearly there are about systems. I'm
not coming to this from a story teller.
I don't really know anything about making
telling stories but if people could do,
but uh,
but we're really a part that I bring to
this is the understanding of systems.
And so like here on this totally
boring looking sheet of paper, right?
I mean you can see some
ideas forming about like,
oh like these are some parts and
these are some differences. Like some,
some abstract and differences
between like, like what's
the difference in flavor,
what's the difference in emotion
between a micro controller and a DSP?
And like in reality they're kind of the
same and they're just kind of like tune
different ways.
But like there's,
you can think about it in an abstract
way that's like an abstraction that has
feelings of like, oh, dsps are really good
at math. And like there's certain, there,
there's certain ways that they're
different and like there's,
there's asymmetries that you can explain
it when making a puzzle game and said
there's this sort of just like high
level like ideas of things that might be
mechanics and like, uh, in this case
it's based on a real life system.
This is sort of where the game starts
out and it probably doesn't spend that
much time in this period. Um, I
like to think visually, right.
So the best thing to get out as an idea
or some, some visual ideas of like,
how would this look like as a system
you interacting with? Right. And I mean,
so we've got a sketch it over, over on the
left side. It was curious or somewhere.
So, um, this looks a lot like a node.
And I know with the exception
of that depends coming up
the top and, uh, you know,
you, you start to see some ideas kind of
forming just in these little sketches.
And so I'm definitely a big fan of, of
drawing stuff to, to do that. And so,
so from the,
the basic high level ideas and the
emotions that turns into some sketches or
start to kind of visually explore
some stuff like that. Um, we,
we for change and I own particular,
we interviewed a bunny Juan,
the engine guy and who everybody
goes to for anything about Schengen,
which almost seems kind of kind of cliche
that we did, but he actually, you know,
like everybody does, he know that you
learned something good from him and a,
and he told us about some more things
that were kind of like emotional points of
doing development and engine and uh, like
midnight partner, you know, going to a,
like a, the electronics wet markets
where it's just stalls, installs,
installs of electronics and just like in
the middle of the night and you're like,
wow, we need like 10,000 transistors, this
certain type, like time to go buy some.
And then you come back with
a box of 10,000 transistors,
which actually isn't even that big.
And uh,
and like these are sort of like the
emotional things that I think go into,
I mean, how many of you have [inaudible]
out? Right? So, okay. Some of you.
So it's a game about on the surface you,
you build circuit boards and dropdown
ships and in rate code for them.
And then they do things they generate
like timing diagrams and they do stuff and
uh,
but it's also,
it has a pretty intense story where
there's a lot of emails of the people you
work with.
This company in Shenzhen being told and
they're funny and they argued some times
and all of that stuff is
informed by things that we
learned about like what it's
really like to be like an ex
pat in China and all of that.
And I mean we don't really have
any firsthand experience with it,
but we were able to get that
from, from talking to um,
some actually some, some devices
that were invented in Shenzhen,
which we didn't turn
puzzles turned into puzzles.
I the Barbecue Times that tell you the
temperature of the thing you're talking.
That was like an original Shinjin
invention. Not, not like a knock off.
And same thing with the hoverboard,
although like I guess there's a market,
planet money or whatever
about the debates, the, the
origin of the hoverboard.
Um, so the, the thing I like to do,
this is really kind of diving
into my personal process,
but I love making like little like black
and white gray scale pixel art that
kind of lays out like what,
what am I actually going to be dedicating
screen space to write and like this,
this I guess some,
some people when they start making a game,
let's start with concept
art. But for me it's, yeah,
like incredibly detailed technical looking
things and cause this says just share
like what is, what is the information
that's being depicted in this game?
Like what, like what are we, what are
we dedicating space too? Like you can't,
you kind of can't just say like,
oh we're just going just to be able to
code stuff and they just make it scroll.
I have a huge aversion
to scrolling in games.
Like [inaudible] was the first game
I've ever really made where everything
doesn't fit on the screen
all at once at one time.
And like there's a reason for
that and it's because if there's,
I don't know if anybody's read like the
tough, do you like design books? Right?
He talks about like the PowerPoint effect.
The lousy thing about
PowerPoint presentations is
that as soon as I flipped away
from something, you're going to
forget what I was just showing you.
And if you can't kind of look
at two things side by side,
it makes it really hard
to compare them visually.
Like that's a huge part of how
our brains work. So, um, yeah,
so everything fits on one screen.
Most in most electronics games, all,
we're slightly pulling away from
that like machine engine. But uh,
but we can look at information. Um,
here's the design of Schengen solitary.
It was just on this piece of paper.
Um, from there we have to come up with,
and this is I guess sort of a
newer thing with electronic scans.
When we did space camp, I have,
who's plays Bass Con. Cool. Okay.
So one of the biggest flaws perhaps what's
base camp is that all of the puzzles
just have you make chemicals for no
reason at all. Right? It's just like, oh,
we need a bunch of s settling because, and
like that's it. And that's like, that's,
we have a story and the story's over here.
And then we asked you for acetylene
over here and there's no like connection
between the two. And one of the
biggest complaints we got from, from,
from space camp was that,
um,
it would be great if there was any kind
of story justification for why you're
building what you're building any at
all. And uh, and that was, I think that,
I guess that was one of the ones that
really resonate. I think it was like,
oh yeah, that's right. Like they
don't mean anything, you know.
So with trying to think, I guess
with, within Finna factory,
we started exploring with that.
Like what if you could make things
that actually fit into the story and we
Shinjin we wouldn't even harder with it.
And so every puzzle in Shinjin is based
off of a little pitch that our writer
wrote and that we brainstormed before.
But we turned them into these things like
we want to build a little story around
each puzzle and a,
and we want to like bring that puzzle
to life by creating a context around it
that gives it meaning. Um, and I think
it was really successful. I don't know.
I mean you guys can, can tell me. Um, so,
so in this case, I mean like how did it,
there's tons of ideas here for puzzles.
A lot of them we didn't do,
cause they're really hard to turn into
like a magic baseball bat. I'm like,
this is, this isn't our sort of near
future. Everything is lousy or future.
Um, we uh, yeah, okay. I was going to make
a political check but I'm not going to.
But um, but you know, the idea
like, Oh, magic baseball bat,
it's like the selfie stick or the
baseball bat of selfie sticks I guess.
Like it just makes you hit a
home run every time. Right.
And it fits the medically,
but it's kind of hard to think of like
how do you make a puzzle that like,
is that, and I guess
it's like, I dunno. So,
so not all the ideas really make the cut,
but we got a lot of my good ideas here
and then we start turning them into
puzzles.
And so one of my other little quirks is
that I like the design every puzzle on a
sheet of paper because then you can
start them separately. You can right now,
like we're working on a game that has
puzzled like things in it and they're all
pinned up on the wall. Like I'm some
sort of like person, like, like uh, like,
like detective that went rogue and it's
like all the connections drawn up on the
wall and like the string
running in between them and
I can see the pattern. Yeah.
So with,
with paper you can do that is that you
can pin up all your designs and you can
see them all at once and you can use
your sort of like the visual part of your
brain to, to, to see like, Oh,
do I not have enough of the,
this mechanic being represented or
whatnot. Um, making forms was fun too.
I guess that's like a more of a reflection
of my personality that I like making
forms and filling them out. But so from
there, yeah, I mean we just, you know,
like every, every puzzle has its
own little little form. And uh,
to get back to your original question,
which I think I have to virtual highlight,
which is how much time do we spend making
the original mechanics versus coming
up with puzzles?
Um,
I'd say it sort of that there's a
little bit of time up front, uh,
for coming up with the
mechanics of the game.
And then I like to just try to make a
whole bunch of puzzles without even being
on a plan, which I guess is another
word, electronic state that we make all,
I make all of my puzzles without
really testing room. And then, um,
the ones that don't work don't
go in the game at the end.
Sometimes they do and then they get
replaced afterwards and it Kinda,
I don't know,
I mean our games are really open ended.
Like our games are usually that we built
a tool set and then we bought a bunch
of challenges and we build
them independently so that
way you can kind of tackle
the problems however you
want with the tool set.
And that comes across in the end,
the puzzle design kind of
mechanism that we follow. Um,
I guess the other thing too is
that especially with Schengen,
we change our toolset as we realize
like what is possible and what isn't
possible in with the tool set. And they'll
give you, while you saw the puzzles.
And so like essentially like a really
boring example is the memory that all of
our memory used to be that like you'd,
you'd write to it and it would store the
values and you'd read from it and then
you get them back and that was all you
could do and it turns out that's like
really useless.
And if you wanted to like read from it
non destructively you'd have to read and
like everything and then somehow rate it
back in and it just made everything too
hard. And so like right up until
the last minute of stringent Ya,
we were still changing
mechanics in the game.
So that's like you never really get to
stop working on your mechanics or your
puzzles or anything. I don't, I
don't know what the moral there is.
Does that answer your question person
who didn't ask that question? Oh well
does that answer your question?
Person who did ask that question?
This one is actually from someone who's
not, how do you make your games fun?
I've tried to make educational games
in the past and might have turned out
pedantic and Fiji whereas
yours are actually fun. Does
that your question? Oh, I,
this is the person that I wanted to
grill so I wanted to find out like why,
what makes them think that Tektronix games
or educational or what makes them fun?
Right. Because it's possible
that they're neither, but yeah,
to constantly easier if I
had somebody to escalate it.
Does anybody want to like proxy
for that person and like feel,
has anybody tried to making educational
games here and there like disappointed
without it was that, was
that a hand raised but just
to stretch. Okay. Yeah. So,
um, I guess I have to imagine, Oh,
you can proxy to be if you want.
I have done a little bit of work and
we can be educational games. Yeah.
Years ago as a contractor
and I also do find these games fine.
Yeah. The answer perhaps as to why. Okay.
Do you want a proxy through be,
go ahead.
Sorry. That's what, what's your
opinion of educational games?
Oftentimes it seems like there's some
particular lesson that equal that is the
creator and the educational game
watch these students to learn. Um,
and it's very difficult to make that
into a game and it doesn't fit anything
bear. It just so happens I think
that we're particular mentality.
Engineering is fun.
Yeah.
And so if you could make a game
where you're just doing it,
engineering the fun parts,
then it stopped how educational
but also still fun. Yeah.
I like for me,
I will say personally as somebody who
came into computer science through,
maybe it did have a nontraditional
route actually vaguely computer science
education,
um,
Shinzen Iot as were up 141st time that
I ever actually did a separate program.
Oh yeah.
Also I learned something there.
Yeah. That's okay. So, so that's, that
was the perfect answer. Thank you. So,
um, so my, my personal, I
mean for me I guess God, okay,
so space cam made space.
Kim was like, okay, this,
this game looks so educational.
Like if I believe that,
like pretty pretty thoroughly
believe that like we can,
if only we can make
education like space camp,
everybody would love it
and it would be great.
And like you know this kind
of like the idea of taking,
taking systems and problems and presenting
them to people in a way that they can
solve them and an open ended
fashion without having to
just like learn stuff and
recite it later.
Like that seems like it would just blow
education wide open and a and it didn't.
And so I started really enthusiastic
and we made these educational games once
that I showed you before. And like I,
I would say as we were doing the projects,
my enthusiasm kind of
like crashed pretty hard.
And by the time we got to the end it's
like, why are we making these games?
And I think that like part of,
part of the problem was that when we
make a game for real, we, it just,
it just is what it is. And we
put it out there and we say, hey,
whoever wants to play this,
play it. If you like it,
you'll let us know by buying
it or whatever. But you
make an educational game.
Like they were testing him and they were
like forcing the kids to play them and
just like sitting them down and saying,
you're going to play this game now.
And then the kids would play it cause
they were told to or whatever and if the
game, so I guess it's better
than like do this math problem,
like kind of not like they didn't,
they don't really have any agency and
doing that, which is a big thing and game.
And uh, and then they asked
them afterwards, they're like,
now they're never going to quiz them on
what they learned. And it's just like,
Oh God, like these kids, they're there.
They're, they're like in middle school.
Like they're not really good at expressing
themselves. And even if they are like,
they're just kinda like,
like saying the answers are
not saying the answer is it is,
you're just so far divorced from what
it is to make a game at that point.
Then it's just like it for
me, it destroyed all of like
the motivation. It's like,
why are we like,
are we improving their lives by making
these games and making them play them?
And it's like, well,
not really because it,
and then you start getting
the question for like, look,
what is the point of education, right?
Like in curriculum. And I guess I, this,
this is again a reflection of me,
I guess more than any sort of reality,
but like the, the idea of like the idea
of an educational game, it's, it's,
it's, there's already so much bias just
saying that like an educational game and,
uh, that like it's meant for a school
system. It's meant for a curriculum.
It's really hard to design games to that.
Like you said. And I, I was, here's the,
here's a fun anecdote for me is that I
was at a serious games convention back
when I was in my more naive stage and
thought that we can make educational games
that are great and the Games would
save the world or whatever. And uh,
and somebody,
there was somebody there from full sail.
It was saying that they'd
made an educational game,
but the lesson they learned is that you
have education and you have fun and you
just have to kind of dial in, like
where on the spectrum, like you want,
you want a hint. Right. And
of course their game was
terrible. I'm not gonna lie,
it was a game where you go around and
fight people and then do math problems.
And so it's like there's fighting and
then there's math problems would pop up
and it's like,
okay,
like I guess we can agree that that's
probably not the best way to do an
educational game.
But,
but I actually had the audacity to like
raise my hand and challenge the person
who was talking and just be like,
wait, I like, this is ridiculous.
It's like surely we can make games that
are fun and educational by exploiting
the naturally fun things,
like an engineering,
exploiting the naturally fun
things in the educational content.
And then after having made them,
I actually kind of feel like there's fun
and there's education and you just kind
of dial it in and drop it in.
And like there's, there's,
there's perhaps some reason to
believe that like education,
like learning things is hard and things
that are hard are not fun in the way
that games are. Right.
Like you need like there,
there's all sorts of
stuff about like flat,
like I don't know how many of you
know about like flow theory in games?
Yeah.
The idea that like as you're playing
a game you're going to get better.
And like there's like a,
this is like a graph,
there's an area up here that's like
too I guess like too hard for you and
there's an area down here
that's too boring and so you
just want to kind of stay
in this channel of not
being bored but not being,
having the game be so hard that you
can't play and you can't advance and like
education does not line up with that.
It doesn't fit in.
Like you can't just like they're there
that you can hope that like I guess you
can kind of design a game so that like
people get slightly better or you like
more often than not now you kind of
boost to their power level by giving them
experience and like
upgrading their numbers.
Like this is like a huge thing that's
like the straight game design as far as
I'm concerned. But like it's
like, cause there's, there's,
there's theories about difficulty and a
lot of people like say like, you know,
people, people need to feel better
while they're playing your game.
Like let's just make their, make the
numbers bigger while they're playing it.
You can't do that in an educational
game, right? You can't just say like,
oh your sword now does more damage,
but we're going to give you the same
math problems or we're not going to get,
you can't, like you can't
count on people getting better,
especially at like external skills that
aren't even really part of the game.
That's,
it's difficult.
So I think that moves nicely to how
do you view the difficulty curves and
teaching process in each of your games?
Is there anything you ever wish you had
done differently or anything that you
want to try some day?
I have a picture for this one was more
interesting than trying to explain it.
So this is a graph for space camp.
And so what this represents,
each one had to be used as a puzzle.
These are the blue ones are the sort of
blue ones are required and
yellow ones are optional.
And the red ones are the boss
puzzles, which you have to, they're,
they're a special kind of challenge in
space come. That's kind of hard. Um,
both because it's a hard puzzle and
because it's like obscure as the game play
in a way that makes it harder to solve.
And uh,
and so what this is for each one of these,
how many people started up
a puzzle and then solved it?
And so, um, it's, it's Kinda,
it's kind of the same overall.
We can see the optional positions, right?
There's a lot more people who like,
there's a lot fewer people
who upon starting up an
optional puzzle actually took
the time to finish it.
Every other puzzle in the game were,
was required and often
the sequential order,
which is a thing that we learned
is not a good thing to do. Um,
and so like they're,
they're pretty, pretty good.
The boss puzzles is definitely harder to
the last boss is definitely like people
got to these poor people who
beat every other level up here,
fired up to this level and then only
half of them finished it. Right.
That includes me.
I'm in the people who didn't finish this.
I've never eaten the last
level of space camp and says,
I don't know how you can expect
somebody to like do something like that.
Not necessarily. Yeah, that
would be graph number two,
which looks more like this. So, um, this
one is what happens when you multiply.
Basically you multiply
each one by like the,
all the ones before it and a and have
it fall off. And then, yeah, like if,
if you're, if you fire up
the game, this is your,
your odds of actually
beating the last level,
which I guess makes that fall
off look Lester medic. But
to some degree I would say our games are
pretty bad. But to some degree the game,
you know, like your, your progress
for any game looks like this.
Like I mean how many, how many games that
you guys play? Do you actually finish?
Right? It's probably less than a hundred
percent. And um, so you can actually,
you can look at achievements in other
games. I used to have a slide for this,
but it's on here about like how
many people beat various games.
So like a fashion or no,
um, I guess fashion. Yeah,
like that was beaten by like
15% of people who started it up.
Super meat boy is beaten by about
4% of people who fire it up. Right.
And that's just not a normal like,
like super duper hard mode is like 2% or
1% it's cam is super duper hard, right?
It's like 2%. So it's like 2%
of people who fire up space can,
we'll actually go through
and beat all of it.
And so that's on one hand that's bad.
And that's not really like what I
would want. But on the other hand,
that means that there's a lot of
challenges for people all along the game.
And we actually,
this is something we debate a lot still,
which is like how long should the Gambian,
how hard should it be? And you kind of,
you kind of don't want somebody, well
I guess it depends. I don't know.
I mean it's, it's
possible, perhaps a theory.
It would be that you want people to
play through your game until they,
until they decide to stop.
Right?
It's worse if they play through a game
and then have to stop because they ran
out of content or like some other reason,
right?
Like you want people to choose to
stop and having the game get harder,
like kind of accomplishes that.
And so I, I personally feel like I,
I'd feel disappointed if I don't beat
something, but other people are different.
And, but that's still a debate that
we still, we wonder about. Um, so,
okay.
Playing off this for a second. Okay. Yeah,
I'm just going to how quick you can line
up. But the, um, the thing that this is,
this is actually, this graph is not
really useful. It's, it makes a point,
but it's not useful to us. And
balancing a game, a graph like this is,
this is how we do all of our stuff.
And we actually did a survey in of
factory during early access where we ask
people after they beat a puzzle, we only
showed the survey people would be in it.
We said, how hard do you feel
like this level was? It wasn't it,
was it too hard or was it too
easy or was it just right?
And when you look at the levels that
people say, I beat that level. I'm like,
I feel good because I beat it.
But it was too hard.
Actually correlates close enough for us,
which is not really necessarily
statistically good enough,
but like it's good enough for us.
It,
it correlates pretty strongly with people
who fire it up a level and then never
even be in it. And the, the,
the cool thing there is that we can
measure this without bothering people in,
without asking them and without like
making them kind of English over when was
it too hard or not.
Like we can just track this stat and we
do and then we track with stat and all
of her games. And uh, nowadays something
like this right here would say, okay,
this level is too hard because like
they should all be claimed a flat and I
don't have a picture of
it for infinite factory,
but when in a factory it was pretty good.
Like the easy way,
like the first levels were pretty
easy and then it kind of picks up the
difficulty through here and then it was
pretty flat through the rest of the game
cause we're looking at them
individually and uh, and,
and then sometimes it'd be a puzzle
that spikes up and it was like twice.
It's like, you know, it, it has like twice
the fail, like fell out rate or whatever.
And then that's how we know
that puzzle is too hard.
So that's how we bounce our games.
I don't know if that's the best way,
but that's how we do it.
Um,
do you have any kind of data on how much
the social factor of space can kind of
help people where should keep on
bleeding? Uh, I mean, just the,
this text comparison then Instagram's,
yeah,
because I was one of the
ones that didn't finish it,
but I did come back to some levels
because of the social factor,
Lou comparison with other players and
kind of tried to optimize my solutions.
That would be a good thing to track.
It's hard to tell like why
somebody is playing a level.
And so I think that's kind of why
that's, we haven't explored that. Like,
the big thing I like the,
the first thing I worry about is
people just stopping playing our game.
Because if you can't, if you can't play
a game, it'll be impossible to enjoy it.
Right? And so, so that's
sort of our first priority.
That would definitely be something
interesting to explore. Um, the idea of,
of what keeps people coming back. Um, to
some degree we're a little cynical, right?
That like you compare, like does it
does a new customer, like, you know,
we could have somebody keep playing
the game for longer or we can get a new
customer and like, which
ones, which one is better?
A one theory we have is that the
longer that somebody is playing a game,
the more likely it is to
expose their friends too.
It sort of like if somebody
has a cold for longer,
they're more likely to share it with
their friends in a similar way. Um,
and so that's something we think
about but have very little data for
where did the idea of
having the social parts,
oh, I, I have a thing for that somewhere.
Oh, right here. Oh yeah. I have this,
this is fine. What we'll get to,
this'll be like the ending thing.
Maybe I'm just gonna do the beginning
of it. So I'm with the codex. Uh,
so I made this game. It was just a
flash game. There were no histograms.
There are no leaderboards.
Um, but there were,
there were forums where people would
start competing with each other
spontaneously. This happened is they'd
be like, oh, that's your solution.
This is my solution. It's, it's better.
Like I was able to shave off five cycles
by doing this and they'd share it and
they'd just be like one upping each other.
And we thought of this when we did space
camp and the ways that we kind of made
this a real thing we made an official
was with histograms wear out.
But the funny thing is actually we weren't
on steam for a while, a space camp.
So we couldn't do leader boards that
because we won't have to like roll our own
little litter word service or something.
I don't know. We didn't. So, um, so we,
we only had the histograms and then the
leader boards were just sort of an out,
almost like a, it wasn't very
deliberate. Right. We're like, oh,
steam offers friend leaderboards,
friend leader boards are good. I drank,
I'd heard somewhere probably like a GDC,
like global leader boards are useless
because obviously they are right. Like,
you're not going to be number one,
you're going to be number
like 10,000 no one cares.
Friendlier boards are
like get people riled up.
People like friendly towards and it
just kinda made sense for or against.
But again, like we, I felt
like I didn't think about it.
I don't remember thinking
about it very hard.
I think we just kind of added it because
it seemed like the right thing to do
for getting on steam kind of naive then.
And uh,
and I think honestly the leaderboards
and probably better than the histograms.
Like not everybody has friends who
play their games, but like the,
when I hear like I don't really hear
that many people who are like, oh man.
And then I tried to move my line
to the left on the histogram.
Like it's not the same as like trying to
out cycle someone on the leader boards.
And so in my mind now I think the
leaderboards are almost probably more
important than the histograms.
I don't know if it's going to like upset
like histogram fans out there as our,
your histogram fan.
Cause I have like I don't have
any friends who played your dance.
You've got to fix that man. It's like
there's a name for this genre now, right?
Fair
tronics who's compete with each other.
I want to be at the top of the leaderboard
histograms.
Not to try to move my line to the lab,
but to see how far to look. Right. I am.
I had the factory that I did horrible
hacky way and so my cycles graph is up
there and I was like,
Ooh,
yeah, that's, that's
something. Yeah, no, totally.
We would never get rid of the histograms
because they're just too much fun.
All right, I'm going to
syndicate. It gives you a,
it gives you an insight and especially
because our players are so technical,
they tried that and in histograms to
portal too and it failed utterly like it
was just him. Does anybody remember
the histograms from Portal to Oh
yeah. So you're the first person I've
ever met who even knew that they existed,
which I guess means it was like
100% hit rate for being successful.
But our theory on that
is that there are a lot,
now I feel bad saying that there are less
effective cause you liked it but there
it's not as,
it's hard to directly compete in,
in a game like portal too cause you
can't just hit a play button to instantly
replay your thing, your solution. And so
it, it doesn't quite have the same effect.
Although there's tons of action games that
have scoreboards too. So I don't know,
maybe maybe not enough people have tried.
Yup.
When I was at valve I tried to convince
them like we should do a histogram.
Like we should add histogram
support to the leaderboard service.
But I would have had to cut it up myself.
I want to broken at all.
Which game was the most fun to design
and create and which was least, oh
that's I. Okay. So I saw that question
because I've seen all these events.
I don't have an answer for that.
I mean I would argue perhaps the least
fun games to create where the ones that
we bailed on early and you
guys don't know about. Right.
I'm very much like I only
make things when they're fun.
We've definitely started working on games
that started off looking fun and then
as I got into it I just hated it. And
then like when I hate when I'm working on,
I hate my life and it just like
went down and I'm just like,
I got to stop working on this game.
It's not good.
And we've definitely pulled the plug
on a couple of projects cause it's just
like, it's, it's just emotionally
unsatisfying and bed to work on it.
Apparently I learned recently I have a
very strong aversion to recreating work
that other people have done. Then making
games that feel like they're too much,
just like, oh, like every other game
out there has this. And like we,
I need to fucking spend like months and
months making the same kind of crap that
everybody's making already and like
that apparently I don't like that.
So yeah,
out of my favorite game I Shinjin io was
really great because we had just like,
we just moved into a new office.
We just started our team back up.
We just painted the whole office and
read it because our landlord refused to.
And, uh, and we started working on
this game and we're like, I'd already,
I had already had so much time to kind
of like dream about it and like come up
with all these ideas that we just were
able to just start working on it and it
just like really clicked and it
was really satisfying and like,
that's great when that happens.
And so that was probably
the most fun we've had yet.
But maybe that's just like a,
everything is always getting better thing.
Um, yeah. So, uh, I have
sort of a corollary to the,
the previous question that
I was a proxy for the, uh,
the fun versus educational thing.
But this is more about fun versus
productive or fun versus useful.
So like a lot of the games that you've
made and in particular the ones I've been
a fan of, like ts 100 and Jens
and I, oh. And Space Camp,
you're doing some work,
you have some tasks that you're supposed
to solve and it's an interesting
problem solving challenge.
Um,
have you thought about any ways to try
to somehow bring the fun that you've
managed to create in those
games into more useful work?
In terms of either like making our day
jobs as programmers more fun or making
the fund that we engage in recreationally
more useful. Can it be done by you?
Have any thoughts on what we
might do to make that happen?
And I also asked this
as somebody who is like,
obviously you have worked professional
corporate engineering jobs where it's
maybe less fun than ideal, uh, for, you
know, your programming capabilities.
I'm just curious if you had any
insight on what we might do to,
to bridge that gap.
So,
so this ties into sort of like,
I used to think that games
were great for education.
Now I think that games and education are
just game designers. They only hammer,
they have as game design.
And so everything looks like
a game that needs to be made.
And I think that when I, I guess I don't
know anything about education honestly,
but, um, when I, when I think about
how maybe we could improve it,
it's not by bringing over games, but
by bringing over this idea of like, of,
of fun and the idea that work can
and should be fun. Like if you're,
especially if you're a kid and it
doesn't, right? Like you're, you're like,
it's the, the home the way,
like, I mean there's, there's,
I guess it's sort of an open question
about white people play and why play
exists,
but the idea that play is how we learn.
Like I think there's a lot of evidence
for that and like kind of trying to bring
more play into, into learning,
right? I mean, I think that's a,
I think that's a lofty goal, but I
don't really know if that makes sense.
Or if you could apply that in any way.
Um, as for, for making work more fun.
Oh God. I Dunno. I mean, so they've kind
of roll back into your question earlier.
Um, the games that we make seem like
they are about real life things,
they're kind of inspired by it,
but they're completely artificial.
And I don't know,
I'm trying to think in,
in Shinjin io like we completely changed
the way that synchronization works like
a week before shipping because too many
of our play testers were stupid and
couldn't understand it.
And of course by that I mean it was not
a good system because when you're an
assistant designer, if people don't
get it, it is 100% your fault.
And we had to change it.
And like if we were trying to make a
game that was about real life Arduinos,
cause people need to know how
to program Arduinos right?
When you can't change it, you just have
to kind of like hit a little harder. Like,
oh we'll just put some more
tutorial text on there or something,
which doesn't work by the way.
Like the only way to make a game where
playable is just to make it more playable
into redesign it until it is.
And so it's sort of like, uh,
like the old saying about like,
you know,
the way to win a battle is to
pick the right battle. Right.
And that's very much what we do is that
we take on tasks when making these games
we take on like it looks like work,
but we're really taking on the tasks
that were, we think that we can win.
And education, I think it's much harder
to do that because like you can't,
you can't change anything about it. Like,
all you can do is like, like in, in our,
in our stretch metabolism game,
when we ran into problems,
we just kind of backed off
and like didn't, didn't
cover those topics. And, uh,
I'm like,
you can't do that when,
when you're supposed to be teaching
specific things. So my, my one grade Oh,
you can do, can sit down, but yeah,
I don't want to make you stand there just
to listen to me. Yeah. Yeah. Um, the,
the one and the one idea of, I've seen
an education that seems really cool.
And again,
I say this is like a person who knows
nothing about education from a technical
standpoint is the idea of um,
like a cross curricular classes.
So instead of saying you've math class
and you have history class and this is
something they have at the,
there's a school,
a charter school called quest to learn.
They have a few locations,
you have like a code breakers class.
We're codebreaker classes
about codes and breaking them.
And that's like what the class is about.
And of course that includes
math and history and like
you can't take a class and
not right,
but like it's about code breaking and
it's about something that you can get
excited about as opposed to an
abstract like group of tools,
which is not super fun.
And I think that's like a way
that you can kind of take like,
like games aren't like this is a like this
is a moving game, right? It's like no,
like games. Like if it's just about moving
like, and it's like what about shared?
No, it's just about
moving. Right? Like I said,
there are some games that
technically are that,
but that's not how you go
about designing a game.
Like you try to have like some emotional
resonance. You tried to make it so it's,
it's interesting you give people tasks
so when they like when something's too
hard,
they don't just have to like try harder.
They can kind of back off from that.
I was,
I was just talking to the Keith
and I still work with about,
we've been really into
heroes of the storm.
I put the games I play are
nothing like the games I make.
I am super low brow and my games and a
withhold I play and so we've been playing,
here's the storm, which is a Moba for
those of you don't know. And one of the,
apparently there was a talk by the lead
designer at league or the riot with
League of legends.
One of his philosophies is that you want
to have lots of different skills for
people to master so that when
like you get in a situation,
we're gonna like you keep trying to do
this thing and you just can't do it.
Cause you just don't have that skill
and you're not good enough yet,
you can back off and do
something else instead.
And like if you think about math class,
it doesn't allow you to kind of like
back off and do something that you can do
and gain mastery in a different area
and then come back. It's like, no,
we're just going to keep building
on it over and over again.
And if you miss one step, you are
out. And like that's how we do it.
And like that's a,
that's a very ungainly way to do that.
Like if that was a game that would be
a bad game. But because we don't like,
like we, we say like, oh we want
to bring games into classes.
Not that we want to bring
lessons from games into classes.
I'm going to stop ranting about that
cause I don't know what I'm talking about.
So,
uh,
so the exact term games I've been playing
are often about developing solutions
for like a fixed problem and everybody's
kind of graded against the, the same, uh,
criteria I, he'd have like
their compared, um, you know,
like indirectly if you have
metrics, completion time and
everything like that. Uh,
what do you think about games were
like players solutions can compete or
cooperate directly with one another.
So it's not so much the, you know,
the environment and like a fixed
puzzle, but rather, you know,
you know how they interact
and that's a good idea.
I've ever heard of the rubber wars.
Oh yes. Oh yes. No, I'm
definitely familiar with a
lot of those kinds of things.
Yeah. That's, that's, that is
something that, that intrigues us.
Hmm.
Maybe if you're lucky. Yes. It
takes a while and make games.
That's the hardest part. And
so I, I would, I would love
to make a game like that.
Hmm. So we're probably
gonna have to wrap up soon.
So we're just going to end up with the,
with the question that we deferred,
which is what has been the most surprising
or unexpected thing until two 30
right?
It's in two 30 on this.
Okay.
So we have the room reserved
for cleanup afterwards. Okay.
Well we can start
cleaning off while I talk.
So I wanted to show you guys
something really quickly,
which is the secret origin
and Zach tronics games.
It's just j flap. Has Anybody used
this before? Yeah. You look excited.
So I,
in college I took a class about like
models of computation and computational
theory and one of the exercises that
we got repeatedly was like, you know,
like implement a push, like a, like
an autonomous automata automata for,
um, that, that satisfies these
things and accepts and rejects the,
is these different things and build a
Turing machine. This is that tronics game,
right?
I mean there's actually,
I came out there by somebody
else called manufact Toria,
which is literally about turning your
shins, but like this idea of like,
okay,
here's the set of criteria.
Here's a completely open space where you
can design something that's technical
and kind of computation knee
but not literally programming
and have it like meet
these criteria over here. And I think a
lot of people who make programming games,
they never, they never got to
experience the beauty of Jay flap. Uh,
and they just thought, oh, I have
to write code and then do this.
And I think the thing that really like
this really tapped into something deep in
my psyche,
the idea that like you can build these
things that aren't code but are symbolic
or mechanical or processes and still
apply the sort of programmatic like
criteria to them.
And so that's the hidden,
that's the hidden origin of
Zach tronics games. There's,
I wrote this and I have no idea
what any of this means. I, yeah,
I don't remember anything
from od comp yet.
It was still like the most
important class I took in college.
So,
um,
oh God. Yeah, that was just talking
about Java. But yeah, that was, yeah.
So I'm going to blast it. Do this and
like three minutes apparently. So,
so we get surprised by your
players. A lot of times, um,
people build an impressive things,
obviously, like everybody's seeing like,
like red standing computers in Minecraft,
like that kind of thing of people just
building something that's surprising or
not surprising, but just
like impressive. Um,
sometimes at our games people discover
unintentional mechanics and exploit them
to great depth, right? Like
that's, that's a fun thing.
And sometimes people just find
out new ways to play our games.
So I showed you this about
the origin of histograms. Um,
this is also where solution
sharing and space, Kim,
it really looks like this as youtube
videos. But before that we were like, oh,
what if it was like a website that it
generated and you could click on it and
stuff. It turns out you look at this, you
have no idea what's going on here. Right?
I don't know what's going on there.
I mean,
technically I guess that's
a solution to a puzzle.
But that was why the
video came about. And, uh,
and that was back when it was like super
hard to record a video without like a
codex. And, uh, management
network and construed door.
And you'll see the first, uh,
the first universal solution that you can
buy, like connecting up the wires here.
You can build like any,
you can just replicate any
set of output universally.
And so this, this leads to something
we call a Volkswagen thing. Now,
after people did this to
great degree in Schengen area,
which is where you say to hell
with what it's supposed to do,
let's she and like just get the right
output, you know, like the right,
the right criteria for the
test. So that's, that's,
that's somebody else's term that's
not mine. Um, and an infant, a minor,
we were surprised by or players,
uh,
I built in front of my
kind of play like TF two,
like it has teams and classes and stuff.
I didn't know anything about game design
that all of our players realize that
it's more fun just to build
shit. That's cool. And,
and this would be a thing where our
players innovated and we're just like, ah,
I don't know what to do.
Right.
And sometimes being at like the being at
ground zero is like the worst place to
see what's going on right where you are.
And that's definitely,
I think what happened with within the
minor, um, with space cam, we have some,
oh that looks terrible. So, um, so this
is like a stall, the stall of Waldo.
These are techniques that we had no idea
where possible until we ship the game
and people started doing them where if
you just put it in a structure like this
and have you just run off,
it'll just repeatedly execute that which
it turns out is really cheap from like
a a score perspective.
There's also like a,
I didn't even think this was possible,
but at a strictly linear solution.
Don't know if you guys
have seen that before,
but that's pretty cool. Um, and people
figuring out the worst example of this,
this is kind of like these are
fun, right? Like this is cool.
Somebody figure out something clever.
Uh,
when people figured out how our bonding
algorithm worked and that each bonder
was technically in like a
sorted list somewhere in memory.
And that if you figured out the order,
you could control the order
precisely in ways we didn't intend.
This is a problem that continually bites
us. Something asked over and over again,
which is that like should something
be deterministic or should it be non
deterministic and if
it's non deterministic,
how do we convey that
it's non deterministic?
This would be probably mentioned
and I know that intention io,
when you run a solution,
every time you run that same test run,
it's deterministic.
But when you get to the next test run,
it's technically not deterministic
from the last one. So, uh, this,
this happens all the time. We added logic
gates. People are like, oh I'm clever,
I'm going to go flip flops.
Right?
So they built a non deterministic flip
flop that if they like took like a class
in electrical engineering,
they know it was done terministic but
because they run the same test run over
and over again, it's deterministic. It
always initialized as the top at first.
And then they get to test one,
two and suddenly it's the bottom one
and they're just like, this is good.
This is a bug in your game.
I get so many emails and they're like,
this is bugging your game. It's like, no,
it's just like part of it's deterministic
and part of it's not and it's,
it's super complicated. Can I
have like five more minutes? Okay.
You guys can leave if you
need to. That's cool. Um,
so this is the greatest thing that
anybody's ever made for any of our games,
which this is a homemade,
like they made it by hand.
It's a looping animated Gif and we were
going to do youtube video uploads for
infinity factory.
And this was like 2013 when like everybody
was getting really into animated gifs
again and uh,
and they made this and it just,
Oh you can't talk cause you can't
actually put animated gifs in PowerPoint.
It turns out. And uh, and so
like they made this gift and
I'm just like, oh my God,
this is the greatest thing
I've ever seen in my life.
And so within like a day
I took our youtube thing,
just ripped out all of the video stuff
that we were planning to do and made it
spit out animated gifs instead.
And it was the most genius thing we ever
did because then everybody just shared
animated gifs with all their friends and
they like because of the factory loop,
we can make the gifts loop
seamlessly and it's fucking amazing.
It was my favorite thing.
So here you can see some techniques.
So you actually see,
you can see some techniques that people
discovered that I really didn't intend
and kind of built like with like you
can't do anything about it is that rope.
Damn it.
See if this put it in me,
it gets us the Bz so pretty that rotating
things as quicker than moving them on
conveyors because of like
how rotating things work.
And then people also
use this to build giant,
giant rotating arms where they'll
just have these arms that just swing
effortlessly in one cycle
back and forth across the map.
Like to the point where when
people keep their own like, uh,
like high score list with other
people they like on, on, on Reddit,
they do this for all of our games because
we don't have an official high score
list cause I don't want to be responsible
for making sure people aren't cheating,
that they'll say like,
here's your best score,
here's your best score without
giant rotate our arms. Right.
Like it's a huge problem.
But like we couldn't do anything
about it cause it's just kind of weed.
That was the game we made. Like, um,
we also had somebody who,
um, they, this is a pro,
this is a puzzle where you're supposed
to build a machine that you can drive to
like fight off the battle at spoiler
alert. At the end of the game,
somebody built like a
completely autonomous solution
that like perfectly like
100%. So the, the battle. So like I
didn't even think that was possible,
but there they are doing it.
Oh wait, wait, what? Oh Shit.
What's, what's your, what's
your youtube name? Okay.
So there might be more stuffing
from you. I don't know. Um, okay.
So um, so this is a, uh,
you can tell like it's a whatever degree
you call the [inaudible] for that.
A couple people made these, um,
somebody bought a typewriter.
Like it's getting to the point where I
don't even know like, cause all sorts of,
there's all sorts of cool things that I,
in theory I understand you can do
in the game. Like you can build,
you can build physical structures that
are data because of like their physical,
right? And so I'm guessing that's like
a matrix of like things that encode the
different characters, right? This dude,
like almost all of these videos are
from this guy gtw one, two, three.
So you build a typewriter,
but any build a calculator which uses
the same kind of method for printing.
The crazy thing is it actually
supports a ton of precision because it,
I'm going to skip ahead really
quickly. You can see it, it builds,
it does it physically.
I think you guys can see here this guy,
because he's going to
build this number and it,
it just kind of builds it
as like a stack of blocks.
And then the way you add them as you
just smash them together and let it like
physically carry over and
stopped. So it's pretty cool. Um,
he also implemented tis 100 and an infant.
Yeah.
So
as far cleverer than I am. So I'm,
the code of the program is locked in,
but it is reprogrammable
and it's really execute.
Like I don't even know how
the fuck do you do this?
Yeah,
you consider it hungry?
I don't know.
I don't want this person
writing code for my games.
Right.
Um, so there, there's a little bit of,
these are all going to TRS
is boring by comparison. Uh,
so we had this instruction called Jro,
right.
Which lets you just arbitrarily
tell one node where to jump.
One node can tell another node were how
to jump and it's like you can do the
same things with it. The problem is
that that doesn't look cool, right?
Like does anybody know what this is? This
code? Yeah. So this is the quick three,
like fast inverse, square root thing that
like, it's, it's like infamous code. It's,
it's, it's, it's really hard to tell how
this does an inverse square root. Um,
but it's great code and it's great
solutions for ts 100 look like this.
It's like as it best, like you can tell,
there's a comment here that just says,
what the fuck? So like, you know
that something weird is going on.
Like you don't even get that
on task because there's not
room for such a comment.
So like good t I s solutions don't
look any different than a bad one.
Some people built little fun things like
this generates amazed that you can walk
around in, but that's about it. Uh,
a lot of people built emulators for TSL
hundred. I guess that's kind of cool.
Like,
like there was surprising number of people
who made emulators for Canada's 100,
which I guess is how program we're going
to interact with stuff as to try to
emulate it has some fun stuff
and sound going to come through.
MMM,
okay.
So the, Oh, I can hear myself going
through that. That's what's going on.
That's confusing. Um, I'm
going to try to, okay. Um,
can we link to the microphone
into the computer? Does that work?
We'll try it in a second. So this is one
of those people who bought a flip flop.
That's not a terministic
they, uh, they think it is.
Um,
well that does seem like an error.
That was just supposed to
be funny. Okay, here we go.
So here
somebody built a game of life.
Like these are just things that I
didn't even like. I guess that works.
Like evidently it works. I
don't know how it works. Right.
And there's a bunch of that we shouldn't
and I know the best ones are the music
player ones.
So we're going to try this.
Yup.
That's just going to be feedback. That's
not gonna work. Um, this play music,
which is hilarious. If we could,
you could hear it. So, uh, that,
that kind of doesn't work.
What's that joke? Um,
so here's the last thing I'll show you.
So somebody built a,
a three d maze or you can
like walk around. This means,
and the way that they couldn't
actually store the maze anywhere.
So it like it algorithmically generates
the same maize every time because
otherwise you just wouldn't go to fit it.
Right.
And so all the crazies engineered
solutions have this train.
Like you just can't even tell how
they work. And it's, it's like magic,
but there's no fun mechanics
to discover in that game.
So I think the giant rotator arms are
probably the best for what somebody has
done. So that was another quick
thing that I show you guys.
Somebody asked about the s 100 patches
and so that was totally inspired by
Activision. Used to give away.
I get, I don't know if they,
you had to send him money,
but if you photographed yourself getting
a high score in a m and it would a game
and like next to the TV or whatever and
then you send them the photo and then
they'd send you back a patch
so you could like join,
they're like high score club or whatever.
And so I saw this and was like, yes,
we need to do this for,
for like Infinera factory.
And so that's where like the first 100
the first 100 people to beat all of the
puzzles in the first part of the
game, got a patch and a, and it was,
it was pretty cool. Yeah. I
guess we should start off then.
Does anybody else have any questions?
We have time rate.
Thank you for coming here.
Round of applause.
[inaudible].